foreign
hi Rachel welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
hi thank you so much for
sure I my husband and I my husband and I
have been trying we've done day dish for
about 10 years and we've made every
mistake you've ever told anybody not to
do
um and if you saw us in person you would
probably flick us upside the head
not you just your husband
no well maybe maybe just him
um so my problem is we are trying to be
we're trying to actually do the baby
steps um without actually doing the baby
step at this time my problem is is when
we line up our debt
um we have a huge bill to the IRS
um we owe currently about twenty five
thousand dollars
um and so it's it would be our biggest
debt next to the house and so I I think
I know the answer is that we don't put
that at the bottom of the list we would
attack that first that's right right
that's right yeah so what do you owe on
your home
um 280. what's it worth
about 300 320.
hmm
uh
is your credit screwed up with all these
other problems you've had
no our credit is fantastic we have a
huge credit score Dave okay
um I would go to the bank and talk about
some kind of home equity loan I'm not
sure you got enough equity to do it but
if you can pull 25k off your house and
pay the IRS off I would
yeah
because I'd rather owe the bank than the
IRS the IRS has the highest fees the
highest interest and almost unlimited
power to screw with your life
yeah and and they're doing it yeah I
would want them out of my life as fast
and as much as possible you don't want
to deal with the KGB if you can help it
so if you can borrow from anybody you're
going to have a better deal than they're
giving you
and get them out of your life that's
that's going to be and so as Dave Ramsey
telling you to borrow money no Dave
Ramsey's telling you to take one kind of
debt that you have and move it to
another kind of debt
so it's not that's not it's not new
borrowing we're just transferring we're
changing the shape of the debt uh to
make it better to make it more
manageable what's your household income
one 30 about 125 130. good and what uh
where did the IRS debt come from
um
a stupid mistake with zeros on it my
husband told he left one job and decided
to have a little fun for a while and
pulled a whole bunch of money out of his
401 uh so it's a one-time stupid thing
and you know not to do it again so it's
not going to reoccur oh that's
absolutely no I'll kill him first
um yeah and so we're the taxes are still
due if he's dead so let's just keep that
in mind
at least we'll have a good life
insurance policy job though well until
they discover the murder part but yeah
Jefferson on that part
all all joking aside have both of you
had enough of this are you both on board
yeah yeah well I I I'm definitely
because what do you describe with him as
an unbelievably irresponsible Act
yeah that's not an ish that's not
assorted to Dave Ramsey that's I just
went off the deep end of insanity for a
few minutes yeah and I can't fully blame
him because I had some fun in there too
but um yeah we lived like kings for a
year well this is the kind of fun that
leaves a hangover that lasts for years
it definitely does yeah
the thing is yeah I would go borrow on
my house as a part of my complete life
transformation
but not as a way to try to escape
responsibility for my stupid actions
yeah
so if you're gonna go play all the way
through and get all these debts paid off
yeah do that but if not what I'm telling
you is not really going to help you it's
just a small part of the overall thing
um my concern would be if I borrow from
the bank and this is going to sound
stupid I know because I know the answer
is the interest rates right now are much
lower than the IRS they're still going
to be better okay they're still going to
be better okay because you're also
getting compounded late fees
yeah the penalt the penalties are what
get you with the IRS and do they have
unlim they can disrupt your life they
can come just take your paycheck or put
a lien on your house or I mean their
power is no other creditor has anywhere
near the kind of power they have no bank
I mean Banks if they wanted to sue you
it would take them forever if they want
to foreclose it takes them forever the
IRS just slaps people around when at
will and they do a horrible job
communicating with you you gotta wait
for a letter in the mail if they decide
to send it you just you really don't
want to be at their Mercy it's not worth
it and so yeah I really don't care about
the interest because again it's the law
it's let's say that all of a sudden one
of your checks was gone
um so that that's a bigger deal than
interest rate for you getting your life
straightened out
yes that's why I'm doing this so yeah I
want you to get control of the variables
that we can control